Candidate Donald Trump told the American
people he was going to move the US
Embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem. But President Donald Trump –
despite rumors – hasn't done the deed.
Now, every Republican candidate has
always promised to do this. None have ever
done it.
So are they rethinking putting the US
embassy in Jerusalem, or are they just going
slow on that? One reason the president
may be hesitating is because of Israeli
settlements policy to which he's
expressed some small objection. Another
reason may be that he just isn't sure
how to do it.
There's nothing really wrong with the
idea: After all, West Jerusalem isn't
disputed territory. East Jerusalem is
what the Palestinians claim. The real
question here isn't where the embassy is.
The real question is, "What is the basis
for peace between the Israelis and the
Palestinians?" The basis for peace is a
partnership, not about where the
different buildings are. Moving it isn't
going to make all the difference. Having
a Palestinian partner is.
What do you think about moving the US
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem? Let us
know in the comments, and also let us
know what other topics you'd like AEI
scholars to cover in 60 seconds.